a new jersey high school valedictorian
says his school tried to censor his
graduation speech when he began talking
about being a member of the lgbtq
community
in a video seen nearly 200 thousand
times the school's principal grabs 18
year old bryce dersham's microphone
after appearing to disconnect it dersham
says the principal took his speech
and pointed to a pre-approved version
dersham continued with
his speech anyway meg oliver spoke with
the recent graduate
and his parents
it's 2021 but we're still dealing with
this and it just broke my heart
eighteen-year-old bryce dersham says his
principal cut his mic
less than a minute into his high school
valedictorian speech
after i came out as queer freshman year
i felt so alone
i didn't know who to turn to for support
and then just silence and then the
principal came up onto the stage
and he took the paper the speech that i
brought with me to read
and he crumbled it in front of his hand
dersham says he was repeatedly asked to
take
out references about his sexuality and
struggles with mental health in multiple
revisions of his speech
he had spent six months in treatment for
anorexia during his senior year
and didn't even know if he'd be able to
graduate let alone at the top
of his class i want people to start
having
honest conversations about mental
illness you know about
the struggles different groups face in
school
and society how did you feel as a father
watching your son go through that
first i was like he has
more courage than i would ever have
um then for him
and all i did i remember yelling out
grab your composure brunch
[Applause]
and i saw him step back and he leaned
back in
adjusted himself a little bit and he
said as i was saying
and i went you go bryce you go
and then i started thinking and he
validated later i'm like
holy what they think that the
valedictorian
can't memorize seven minutes of speech
in a statement to cbs news eastern
regional high school wrote
no student speaker was asked to remove
their personal identity from
any speech before or during graduation
or stop from sharing their personal
identity during graduation
adding the school is centered on the
accomplishments of all
graduating students and expressed focus
on the graduating class
as a whole you knew they didn't want you
to go off script
why did you do it i thought to myself i
could either
you know give this speech and go against
all of the values
or i could go with my gut and i could do
what i thought was the right thing
all i ever wanted was to let people know
that they are enough thank you and
congratulations
for cbs this morning meg oliver new
jersey
dershon will start at tufts university
in the fall where he hopes to keep
standing
up for those who are silenced uh bravo
bryce
i was giving bryce dersham a round of
applause and so loved his dad too
because you could see the pride
that his dad had in talking about his
son yeah i think he sent
both of them sent a very powerful
message how disappointed you know what
the principle was
i don't know what they were thinking i
mean and that's frankly it's 2021.
luckily bryce is a is a very strong
young man
who's been through a lot but that can be
incredibly damaging to something
it can be i think ultimately the
principal did him a favor in terms of
audience if you weren't paying attention
you learned that chapter got unplugged
dad saying get your composure keep going
and i love bryce coming back
as i was saying as i was saying bravo
bryce brothers